MOVERARE FROM THE CENTER BY RYA
DONATO.
TO ALL THIS DRAMA AS THEY WEDGE
CHOLOWSKI, HIM.
KUHLMAN MOVES IN.
HE'S OFF TO GREAT START IN THE
MONEY, DANIEL SPRONG, LOOKING
FOR RASK.
SPRONG, OUT IN FRONT, ALL THE  .
GOURDE KNOWS WHERE HE'S
BY QUICK.
GRUNDSTROM, BACK OUT TO
WHAT A GOAL BY RYAN DONATO!ING .
DONATO SHOT AND HE
SCORES.
OFF THE WALL.
TRTROR ARVIDSSON, MOVE IN, CH
THE PUCK BEFORE ICING.
GOOD V HE SCORES!
IT THROUGH
THE MIDDLE,  A STICK AND
TIPPED IN.
OUT IN FRONT, PLAY
ETS A PASS,
NO-LOOKER FROM BRENDAN LEMIEUX.
MY GOODNESS, HE" SAVE.
CAN'T GET ONE.
BY BENIERS, BACK HE MIDDLE OF T
ICE.
HERE'S THAT WRIST SHOT THAT
>> JT: SEE HIM STOP THERE
WITHOUT -- I MEAN DEFINITELY  I
BEFORE GRUBAUER CAN GET ACROSS
AND PUCK IS NOT IN THE BLUE --
BECAUSE YOU CAN CHANGE.
DANAULT, PHIL DANAULT AT POINT,
MOVES ITIT BY JORDAN SPENCE.
SPRONG GETS TO IT, TOUGH
SOUCY, TAKEN CARE
ONE, THERE WERE A LOT OF CHANCES
IN